[Music]
think of that powerful memory
make it
the happiest you can remember
it feels like no time has passed
and loads of times past
i think this is the perfect time to sit
down with everyone and reminisce
[Music]
the thing that scared me the most
was the implication that the most
meaningful thing in our life was done
and there's something so joyous about
seeing everyone
and be like
there wasn't though one of the
highlights of my part was when i had to
pretend to be hermione pretending to be
better i don't like to be kept waiting
i've still got the teeth actually i'll
put them in if you want
my sister has children who have been
around 10 11 12 and i said marth i don't
know about this voldemort what you're
being asked to play voldemort
you've got to do it
i wouldn't be the person i am without so
many people here
it's a very overwhelming thing because
i've watched you grow up and i've seen
kind of every stage of your life
when things get really dark and times
are really hard there's something about
harry potter that makes life richer it's
a strong bond that we'll always have
we're family and we will always be part
of each other's life
[Music]
[Music]
you